les ordinateurs de ben laden ceux avec
lesquels il est sans doute en train de
préparer ses prochains attentats est un
dictateur
si j'étais un dictateur j'oblige ray et
thierry ardisson a diffusé chaque samedi
10 minutes en boucle l'image de l'angola
et du burundi qui veut voir si vous êtes
une infirmité
si j'étais une infirmité la surdité
réussir et il a permuté l'assemblée
non la patience 1 l'impatience moi c'est
probablement vous mon pire défaut enfin
voilà la patience un assassin si j'étais
un assassin jeu j'essaierai d'assassiner
pas ma voisine rassurez vous la mauvaise
part de moi-même que je connais bien et
ça en général c'est un crime parfait
mais celui là si vous étiez à microbes
j'essaierai d'être un d'être un microbe
sympathique des train d'être un microbe
du gauche qui irait chercher de
préférence les [ __ ] et parfois les
cons mais surtout les salles aux
microbes sélectif une torture je ne sais
pas si je voulais torturer quelqu'un je
crois que ce serait la différence
voilà une humiliation je me suiciderai
parce que je si j'étais une humiliation
je crois que je ne supporterai unis
d'être humilié ni encore moins de
supporter l'humiliation des autres donc
je disparaîtrai dans votre nuage de
fumée jugement dernier serge lama
j'accompagnerai serre la main au cul rga
thouars
c'est un jeu tant de membres paralysés
si vous étiez un terroriste je serai le
colonel fabien
c'est à dire je serai un bon terrorisme
la définition d'un bon terroristes c'est
quelqu'un qui défendent juste cause et
qui n'a pas d'autre moyen que la
violence de la défendre donc posé des
bombes dans paris en 42 ce colonel
fabien à st je crois que c'est du bon
terrorisme et ça n'a évidemment rien à
voir avec cette caricature que sont les
terroristes devant lui mais c'est comme
faire la guerre sans l'aimer quoi c'est
comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer qui
était un mode malraux et qui est elle a
deux filles la devise du commandant
massoud vrai et si vous étiez de mort 3
je serai très chaud ce serait la petite
mort
[Applaudissements]
andré glucksmann je vous étiez un défaut
vous soyez quoi moi on pire une injure
c'est c'est celui qui dit qui l'est
c'est une maladie se croire bon se
croire un très bon qui veut faire l'ange
fait la bête un accident le genre humain
une perversion un sandwich saucisse
nutella ou d'une glace vanille camembert
si vous étiez une guerre la prochaine
ou bien la guerre de tchétchénie qui
dure depuis 300 ans 1
mais plutôt du côté de tchétchènes
soutien vis un mont blanc mais pas le
papa pas la montagne une meringue avec
un grain de marrons crème chantilly
c'était en fait c'est la véritable
madeleine de proust et ça se vendait
chez rebelles meyer et le magasin a été
débaptisée par les nazis parce que ça ce
n'est pas vraiment tout à fait français
je suis dit c'est une trahison l'oubli
une arme les couverts en matière
plastique du vol mais qu'on a dit vous
étiez un supplice le match télévisé
jospin chien qu une cicatrice celles qui
ne se referme pas
ground zero sujet tient dictateur vous
seriez qui ubu c'est une invention d'un
lycéen 1,88 à 15 ans en 1881 en 1888 qui
anticipe et ben laden et polpot et
staline et hitler et qui en plus est
drôle si vous étiez une infirmité les
pieds dans le plat en assassin
raskolnikov mohammed atta rien de ce qui
est inhumain ne nous est étranger si
vous étiez un terroriste à un terroriste
qui réussit qui fait beaucoup de morts
qui est félicité par tout le monde qui
va boire le thé avec la reine
d'angleterre je serai là d'ymir
vladimirovitch poutine
vous faire un anti part
chinois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gabriel massenet si vous étiez un défaut
la conscience un défaut mineur
c'est pas mal il confond si vous étiez
une injure à une agir alors je parlerai
italien parce que l'italien la langue de
l'amour mais aussi la langue des
insultes je dirais paraboot temps
ouhlala bon de faire ça c'est une entrée
masque alcon kenan c'est beau ça
j'aimerais si vous étiez une perversion
je sais pas dire on en ces temps de
carême je dirais une messe noire
je vous étiez une guerre à le siège de
la rochelle à cause de deux des trois
mousquetaires de d'artagnan rappelé leur
soutien à vis la gourmandise une
trahison parce que je peux rester avec
alexandre dumas je dirais le
le crucifix d'aramis quant à caen 1-1
d'artagnan dit traître tu nous as fait
jurer sur le crucifix d'une frondeuse
cette prolifique offert à ramiste la
duchesse de longueville
si vous étiez une arme à la meilleure
mon cher la seule la vraie le c'est la
seule qui fasse peur aux enfers sabine
des noms si vous êtes une cicatrice un
chagrin d'amour
un poison la ciguë un récent littéraire
ou le jura oui c'est pas mal aussi
si vous étiez un dictateur d'écouté
depuis que beigbeder fait la campagne de
lui je dirais staline ce grand calomnier
car je pense que staline gagne est connu
l'un des points que ces mots si
politiquement correct si vous étiez
grâce à la sner celui-ci une torture à
dents nous savez dans françois 1er
fernandel il ya la chèvre num et du sel
alors ça ça doit être terrible
si vous étiez une mort j'ai écrit un
poème sur la mort
plus tard beaucoup plus tard la radio
les journaux tu apprends donc je suis
mort à cette nouvelle le visage oublié
de ton amant flottera à certains devant
tes yeux ton corps se souviendra de
notre incomparable patients pointé 15
ans se seront rendus ta bouche sera ivre
du vin perdu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez un défaut vous seriez quoi
ou qui j'espère que je ne serai pas
l'envi mais peut-être l'envié si vous
étiez une injure
tabernacle c'est une injure que j'ai
entendu au québec et maintenant comme on
dit ça fait chier partout et même à la
télévision j'ai décidé de dire taberna
c'est dur les chanteurs québécois murat
peux vous en parler c'est yann accident
chute à vélo j'aime bien faire du vélo
mais peut-être que je n'ai pas une forme
olympique et j'aime bien les descendre
car je fais du vélo
michel drucker ici voilà il ya plus de
celle ci vous étiez une perversion
l'amour conjugal une guerre la guerre
des nerfs
un vice la lecture quotidienne de
l'équipe
c'est vrai larry smith will smith
seulement les intellos souvent si ça non
mais moi je sais et c'est cet ancien
café mais voilà mêmes et les sionistes
les jours ouais c'est une trahison à bas
ce serait la trahison des idéaux de ma
jeunesse généreuse grégaire et un peu
débile ouais c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous
je pars remettre de l'huile sur le feu
mais vous pensez que c'est dépassé ça
non je pense qu'il faut essayer de
réfléchir autrement je parlais tout à
l'heure d'un coeur intelligent c'est une
expression je n'ai pas inventé paraît-il
c'est l'expression du roi salomon et en
arène que reprend à son compte
donc il s'agit pas d'opposer l'émotion à
la raison mais il s'agit d'être dans
l'émotion à la hauteur de la singularité
des événements si vous étiez une arme
le pistolet à eau je tiens à supplice
l'écriture une cicatrice c'est dur or je
ne sais pas peut-être une très longue
ligne de la main ouais ça fait toujours
faire venir vous étiez un poison
l'insomnie un impôt assis gt1 un pur jeu
taxerait le bruit à mort une portable le
bruit de vos iphone vous étiez une panne
une panne d'inspiration un dictateur
alors si j'étais un dictateur je
désinventer les portables et
j'interdirais la musique d'ambiance
ah bon ah oui la musique d'ambiance dans
les restaurants dans les cars qui se
passe ailleurs dans la cadre est dans
les temps les magasins inter à la
musique contre la musique d'ambiance
c'est une infirmité peut-être justement
une certaine surdité à la musique je ne
n'ai pas été éduqué dans la musique donc
je suis un peu sourd et je le regrette
beaucoup
j'ai un microbe staphylocoque doré oui
je leur parle belle couleur verte
vous étiez une plaie resign aurait
toujours une torture
[Musique]
la page blanche une humiliation
j'essaierai de pas trop la ramener
si vous étiez un terroriste je change de
métier
vous êtes la cliente idéale à nous pour
un anti portrait chinois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous me décevez mais c'est vraiment mais
j'aurais pété eux
non c'est un vrai public de télévision
alors on était vraiment regarder ils ont
répété la plomberie cas aujourd'hui
attention de lapleau drucker
[Musique]
par exemple et de sylla
c'est un vrai public de télévision je
prête si vous étiez un défaut si vous
souhaitez un accident un accident
médiatique une perversion la fois ci
nous font une guerre
le procès de jeanne d'arc à mener contre
saison que les juges un vice à la vertu
une trahison mentir à soi-même une arme
amour un supplice le vide une cicatrice
les aides de zorro qui fait sur le
ventre des méchants un poison l'opium
si vous étiez un assassin et ben c'était
pas bien de le dire mais moi je suis
tout à fait sérieusement pour
l'euthanasie donc je serais pour aller
tuer des gens qui ont envie de crever et
je le ferai
c'est une torture et demi si tina juin
je te dis ta merde au cou
vous n'allez pas échappé à l'anti
portrait chinois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez une injure grospatapouf
way groupe à tous que je milite pour le
retour des insultes
inoffensif facile sympa oui voilà c'est
ça par exemple si vous voulez y et
mazouté si vous me dites je ne supporte
pas grospatapouf y aller avec toute la
haine que vous pouvez essayer pour voir
grospatapouf voilà vous n'êtes pas
crédible j'ai pas envie de vous taper
non c'est le retour à la paix
si vous êtes une balle avis une maladie
l'acné l'acné parce que ça m'avait
beaucoup quand vous étiez petit
énormément
disons qu'à une époque si on regardait
bien entre mes boutons ont pu voir mes
yeux a constitué un type au niveau
si vous étiez un accident un accident je
serai le début d'une liaison ce que je
suis un très très mauvais dragueur donc
à chaque fois le début c'est un accident
c'est une perversion enregistrer les
chiffres et des lettres et faire des
compiles 1
[Rires]
vous étiez vulgaire la vie de couple
évidemment elle a eu dire que tout le
monde peut vivre un vis à vis le bon mot
mais comme beaucoup d'humoristes ça
m'arrive de dire le contraire de ce que
je pense pour faire un bon beau ouais
donc c'est une vraie un vrai vis une
trahison ne plus être supporters du
paris saint-germain jusque quand les
supporters sa vie et en ce moment on va
voir du mérite pour un supporter du
paris saint germain
donc j'ai numérique
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez une larme le cynisme au
cynisme parce que c'est un état d'esprit
qui permet de relativiser beaucoup de
choses ouais un supplice il serait dire
pauvre hésité une cicatrice avec quelque
chose dont je me suis parmi ces à la fin
des forbans passé restés ouverts et j'ai
du mal à deviner franchement le départ
de bébert si vous étiez un poison la
kryptonite la culture it c'est le poison
enfin c'est la pierre qui fait du mal à
superman parce que quand j'étais petit
je voulais de super héros d'ailleurs
juste bien l'impôt l'autographe je
trouve que c'est l'impôt le plus
sympathique que j'ai payé depuis que je
passe à la télévision et j'ai beaucoup
de mal à gérer ça parce que j'ai
toujours la passion qu'on se fout de ma
gueule
je vais donc pourquoi les gens me
demandent un autographe et en général il
ya deux attitudes d'ailleurs je sais pas
si vous avez remarqué mais il ya des
gens qui ne demandent un autographe dit
mais c'est pour qui pour marquer de
choses fait pas que c'est pour moi
où il ya celui qui assume pas qui dit
non tu peux me donner un autographe
c'est pas pour moi c'est pour ma petite
soeur à wells était commentatrice heures
christophe
vous étiez une panne à la page blanche
ouais ça qui fait le plus peur un
dictateur le pèse personne une infirmité
la renault kangoo sa penderie yeux c'est
très bon
un microbe gérard muller souvent c'est
jim des revenus ont lâché à des
écrivains des intellos qui nous font des
réponses si vous étiez une plaie une
plaie la playstation
ça c'est mon côté je ne nourris donc j'y
vais tranquille pour l'émission une
humiliation faire la vaisselle
un terroriste un publicitaire si j'étais
mort
une pendaison avec un grille pain parce
que si vous calculez bien votre coup
quand les gens vous découvre il ya des
choses qui leur sont à la gueule bien
isabelle mergault vous êtes prête pour
un anti portrait chinois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez le portrait chinoise est
très inquiète et je la sors pas souvent
un petit
d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué qu'elle ne
sortait qu'avec vous donne et on ne la
voit jamais sur un plateau télé on dit
jamais on attend bien une frontière très
fier et très heureux de l'avoir donc
fait gentil avec elle très gentil
jusqu'ici sam à la fin jeudi qu'elle
était bien foutu qu'elle jouait bien
tout va bien bon alors vous connaissez
le portrait chinois donc ces sites
étaient une fleur c'est l'anti portrait
chinois évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
négatif que ça si vous étiez et je
saurai si vous étiez un comique pas
drôle mais je serais moi quand je suis
dans des émissions télé où tout le monde
attend que ce le soit voilà comme tous
les comics regret un peu mine de rien et
vous à quoi je partage votre réponse si
vous étiez un animal malodorant alors là
mon chien est connue bien sûr mais après
son 100 points il pu encore
[Applaudissements]
il s'appelle comment elle s'appelle
vives fécondation in vitro et transporte
près ces embrouilles amer si vous étiez
une émission de tf1 s'instaurerait
l'avenir si vous étiez une maladie
honteuse
une alopécie brutal se perdrait tous mes
poils serait sommes-nous resteraient
commandés faut prendre mon cheveu sur la
langue
[Rires]
si vous étiez une manière de mourir mais
plutôt que mourir dans un dernier soupir
je mourrai dans un dernier soupir en eau
[Musique]
si vous étiez un fardeau pour vos
proches
c'est pas de proches si vous étiez un
film qui fait pleurer alors la santé
vitesse ou vercingétorix et christophe
lambert
on est d'accord
un médicament un cache l1 gros casse n
ya qu ici de son époque
[Rires]
on pourrait écrire les pièces si vous
étiez un crime un ice cream waouh si
vous y étiez une partie du corps pas
indispensable double menton
si vous étiez une coiffure ratez rien vu
rigolez une choucroute jared une voiture
française
nds
je vous ai préparé un anti portrait
chinois alors tu es comment vous
répandez en groupe ou pourquoi anti
portrait à importer chinois s'est par
exemple si vous étiez une fleur vous
dites je serai un mieux lotis sous un
oeil et un anti chinois c'est plutôt si
vous étiez une merde d'accord voilà ses
ventes si j'étais une merde à ses dépens
alors mais je réponds tu serais qui s'il
était une merde
non je peux pas répondre jusqu'à la
personne est ici tu peux préciser que
c'est par une ovation
alors si vous étiez un groupe comique
pas drôle vous seriez qui les robins des
bois al qaïda le givi à si vous étiez un
mauvais prétexte manger des éclairs sous
prétexte qu'il fait pas beau ici
marinade est toujours à mes côtés je
vous étiez une partie du corps dont on
peut se passer
moi j'aurais dit une poitrine opulente
way des cheveux si vous étiez mauvaises
nouvelles et liz may peloter qui n'a
rien à dire qu'il veut mais moi moi la
pire mauvaise nouvelle qu'on pourrait me
dire c'est en fait il faudrait que tu
refasses tout du cp à la terminale
recevoir serait heureuse jeunes hémois
du cpa en maternelle si vous étiez un
faux numéro
les 34 pourquoi ils disent d'intérêt si
vous étiez un produit ménager un
démêlant pour chatte
certains ménages et ça non mais ici si
vous étiez un motif de suicides à moi
moi moi si on me dit tu vas mourir dans
deux minutes je me suicide 1
si vous étiez une femme de président
hillary clinton à 20 ans un monstre un
mérou moi j'ai envie de coucher avec
aucun des présidents que je connais mais
je suis sûr et c'est des mecs comme les
égaux tellement surdimensionné que c'est
forcément tu as us et des ministres
élise si vous étiez une forme phallique
alise infinie balance d'élise une fois
pour lui donne la parole à une forme
phallique voix oui un pénis bah ouais
quand même la forme phallique la plus de
l'artiste
non la tête de maurice
ordonnez voir vous étiez un pays en
guerre monaco j'ai pas lu viana de plus
si vous étiez un fardeau pour les autres
andy pas un fardeau dit à fars dalle
vous étiez une émission de télé on ne
peut pas plaire à tout le monde
présentée par thierry ardisson
si vous étiez à défaut de prononciation
attends moi je serai maurice qui lui a
des mots très simples
qu'est ce que vous en aviez des mots
très simples et qu'il a des
raisonnements qui dit au cap par exemple
c'est très difficile de dire pour mon
lycée il est très très sérieux il à dd
c'est sur des mots il n'y arrive pas
c'est vraiment je n'arrive pas à dire ou
égrainant il décolle pas n'arrive pas à
bobigny pour les gravats des as
on est dans la rade et pour nous c'est
très long silence
c'est un anti portrait chinois alors
axelle red vous connaissez le ventre et
chinois si vous étiez une fleur je serai
un hulotiste car là c'est l'anti
portrait chinois si vous étiez une
maladie je serai un rhume une drogue
je serai la cocaïne
parce que j'ai fait une chanson sur mon
album qui s'appelle blanche neige
ouais ouais cette relance neige et j'ai
comparé la cocaïne à une femme par
lequel on est obsédé
elle se souvient on third cédé par mois
ouais si vous étiez un bruit énorme
avance allez si vous étiez une faute de
goût je serai moi même pas pourquoi je
ne sais pas j'ai dit ma soeur m'a
toujours dit que j'avais jamais mauvais
goût parce que je porte les choses
qu'ont les gens comprennent pas encore à
l'heure mais il attendre un peu de temps
et moi je vais vous dire un truc qui a
pu prendre un pain de philippe val
en sortant je trouve de plus en plus
sexy moi je le confirme
là ce soir reste bouche bée
on a ce que je trouve bon on a connu
accélérait dès l'été elle était bébé
mais là elle devient femme quoi vraiment
bien si vous y étiez
une façon de mourir mourir de rire
ouais une insulte une allergie
elle lit une allergie
un bien lotis si vous étiez une question
qui vous ferait quitter ce plateau ce
serait quelques questions j'étais folie
de rester s'il était arnaud j'aurais dit
que j'allais faire territoire est très
clair c'est normal maintenant avec ce
qui brouille les pistes souvent si vous
étiez une arme le regard qui a une
perversion sexuelle containers si vous
étiez une teinture raté c'est il me
regarde quand tu auras que à axelle red
si vous étiez une blague belge
vous savez ce qui m'ennuie les français
c'est que j'aime pas raconter les
blagues pour contrer parce que
d'habitude il faudra compter deux fois
zut il mauvaises critiques ce qui me dit
qu'elle ferait le record le plus mal
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de mélodie
ah si vous étiez un tournant qui fâchent
j'aimerais tu as ta place la fin moi
j'ai rien pour vous we go again
[Musique]
1 l'anti portrait chinois
super le bouge pas avant le jingle si
vous étiez donc si vous étiez une injure
vous serez veriez quoi comme injures
[ __ ] ciel [ __ ] sièges tu sais si
vous étiez une maladie le syndrome
d'alzheimer plate que tu maladie que
j'ai inventé dans un mois sur est
pressée comme quoi de cette jacobs si
vous étiez un accident mon passage dans
cette émission
si vous étiez une perversion l'écriture
si vous étiez une guerre l'invasion du
japon par la belgique
si vous étiez un microbe la listeria
parce que depuis le temps à la listeria
c'est moins si vous étiez un dictateur
un dictateur éclairé avis le vinaigre
une arme
la fourche est un supplice la gourmette
gourmette
oui quand sa porte et une gourmette oui
si vous étiez une panne ben là j'ai une
panne quoi
si vous êtes une cicatrice celle que
j'ai là si vous étiez une [ __ ]
l'une des 343 si vous étiez un poison
le mercure une torture
le saut mot humiliation
le serre-tête un assassin mois un
détritus ce que je mange
si vous étiez une chanteuse berbère
robert va lui-même a dit sylvain si le
portrait chinois c'est si vous étiez une
fleur lentilles portrait chinois c'est
si vous étiez un [ __ ] qui seriez vous
du bois ouais gomez
si vous étiez une infirmité
l'impuissance pas mûres si vous étiez
une drogue douce
si vous étiez un super pouvoir lire dans
les pensées pour les interrogatoires ça
peut servir
le viagra si vous étiez le guerre guerre
des nerfs si vous étiez une femme femme
à poigne
margaret thatcher si vous étiez une
façon de mourir la pointe des hommes
parce qu'après ça fait punching ball si
vous étiez une insulte îlotiers si vous
étiez une arme un flash ball
si vous étiez une perversion sexuelle
moi si vous étiez une opération
chirurgicale la guerre en irak
si vous étiez une mauvaise nouvelle
coupable si vous étiez un film raté
voilà le gendarme et jeannard m cette
famille si vous étiez un mauvais rappeur
eh ben florange si vous étiez un très
mauvais rappeur faf larage si vous étiez
à pêcher l'avarice la convoitise et toi
tu pas la gourmandise
[Applaudissements]
alors belgique si vous étiez un pays
chaud ouais mais la thaïlande
vous êtes originaire de là-bas ouais
ouais
si vous étiez un film chaud emmanuel
c'est bien moi ça m'a beaucoup marqué ma
gueule quand j'ai vu manuel mata
sexualité a changé si vous étiez une
boisson chaude un chocolat chaud
vous étiez une mer chaude
je retire pas les affaires on a dit
pardon alors bas la mer des caraïbes
ouais pour les caraïbes c'est une
confidence chaude
et
une amie qui me qui me jetterai dans
l'oreille sa première fille nation si
vous étiez un vent chaud vous étiez une
époque chaude 69
si vous étiez un plat chaud brandade de
morue au autobiographie si vous étiez un
mec chaud les miens comment il est alors
très beau il a un métier tout ça va la
mission qu'ils avaient dîné et l'apca
zimbabwe vient pas parce que d'un métier
comment comment il s'appelle benjamin
d'ingérence la mort ni dans si vous
étiez un souvenir chaude parce qu'elle a
un bouquin si vous étiez un objet chaud
mon scooter
si vous étiez un artichaut hardy chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
damman
[Musique]
est ce qu'on a à mélina micro marveaux
benjamin tenez benjamin attention harry
l'agencé très bien donc benjamin c'est
vous donc l'homme show de notre ami
bénédicte martin ça doit pas être facile
tous les jours une française comme ça à
la maison fait comment pourrait il ya un
traducteur en région benjamin sérieux
comment vous fait de sacrés pistolet
quand même c'est impossible c'est à dire
que je suis obligé de me battre toutes
les 5 secondes avec des gens ouais
heureusement je suis assez musclé donc
je me défends comme je peux vous dire
qu'à pas un bouquin comme ça beaucoup de
mecs vont se jeter sur elle en imaginant
qu'elle est chaude en sachant qu'elle
est chaude or le sou
[Musique]
vexés les chinois eric loupe
si vous étiez une injure vous soyez
quelle injure connard une maladie une
maladie orpheline lula quitte à être
malade autant que ce soit tout seul une
perversion perversion la fidélité une
trahison trahison la vieillesse une arme
le silence un supplice l'adolescence un
poison le champagne une fan
une panne de magnétoscope
quand on enregistre un film qui ne passe
qu'une fois qu'on a un dictateur un
nouveau né
si vous étiez une torture bon soyons
littéraire les la lecture des oeuvres
complètes de christine angot ou là une
mort
l'ivresse pour être ivre mort une plaie
une plaie d'argent
et c'est aujourd'hui maison
de plus en plus
votre créature vous êtes déjà rendu
compte de ça est-ce que vous perdez vos
poils oui j'en fais des pinceaux est ce
que vous vous frottez comme ça contre
michel drucker
oui non qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire
ce que vous faites vos griffes sur
laurent ruquier il y là et il a la dent
dure je griffe parfois non non on se
complète bien sâr est-ce que vous jouez
pendant des heures comme le chat avec un
bouchon et bruno masure il jouait le
bruit d'un majeur parfois pendant des
heures non est ce que vous aimez 10
pieds nus quand votre femme vous prend
par la peau du cou oui est ce que vous
aimez les chattes j'en raffole bien on
va vous faire philippe geluck un anti
portrait chinois
j'ai vu que si vous étiez une injure
vous seriez quoi une injure borromée
nommé nouveau souffle et pas à bordel de
merde je fais chier [ __ ] de ta mère de
mes deux matches et y est une maladie la
finul
vous savez ce que c'est ah non c'est une
maladie génétique rare
ouais c'est les gens qui au lieu d'avoir
la raie des fesses verticale ou
horizontale
non mais attendez déco n'est pas parce
que c'est grave parce que si vous
glissez par exemple sur une rampe
d'escalier en qu'il tenait il est normal
ça fait si vous souffrez cilic urssaf et
bonne humeur dans un accident cardio
vasculaire
un vice vice président des états unis a
non le président des gens vis en
lui-même d'ampleur un supplice la télé
réalité
artak supplice du pal pour un chat qui
est pas parce qu il est une cicatrice je
la travaille très bien de son fils du
pal pour un shérif c'est là vu le fric à
6,6 respectueux peut partir merci une
file chez l'aurore et voilà
[Musique]
une cicatrice là une cicatrice de
monsieur un jour ouvert le bras comme ça
et ma femme était ce jour-là enceinte de
huit mois et demi on était à l'étranger
en tchécoslovaquie on est arrivé à
l'hôpital
ils ont cru que ça elle qui venait pour
accoucher ils l'ont emmené et moi je
suis resté la saignée dans la salle
d'attenté avant qu'elle puisse leur
expliquer en tchécoslovaquie
c'était pour moi qui perdent et mon sens
voilà si vous étiez un poison le hareng
la naïade est un poisson un poison mais
beaucoup de harengs ça peut être
compliqué finalement ça comme le foie
gras de mémé d'hélène bien j'en reparle
plus une infirmité vous si vous étiez
menacé ça alors là franchement le
deuxième tireur de ken hill parce qu'au
moins je saurai si vous étiez une p la
télé réalité
si vous étiez une torture de la télé
réalité
si vous étiez une humiliation perdre
dans un truc de télé réalité
il y étiez vous deviez lui qu'un
terroriste nikos aliagas
[Rires]
attention si vous étiez un défaut marina
vous seriez quoi la radinerie way et toi
les marinas pour venger les crimes
délits
tu faisais tiéné injures dit va te faire
cuire le q si vous étiez une maladie
enregistrés un toc toc c'est ça le
travail salon j'écris la thur une pièce
qui sera produite à bientôt
les prochaines est alors de nous la
meilleure vannes pour voir ça commençait
de mai qu'il y ait pour les répliques
c'est d'aller tout vaut faire reculer
c'est bien je tâtonne belvilla syndrome
gilles de la tourette donc c'est normal
qu'ils disent
si vous étiez une maladie ou un petit
rhume mais avec plein de morgue
voilà c'est exactement ce que j'allais
bien si vous étiez un accident alors moi
je serais un accident très idiot qui est
arrivé pour de vrai à la mère d'un ami
elle s'est auto écrasé avec sa voiture
c'est à dire qu'elle était dans un
parking de son parking lac était en
pente et elle a oublié le frein à main
est sorti pour prendre un truc pas le
pied s'est coincé et attendait c'était
très grave parce qu'on a dû lui ôter les
deux poumons tout d'abord je retire mes
rivaux si vous étiez une perversion
marina est vieillot fini
je vous étiez une perversion je serais
ce que vous m'avez proposé de faire en
coulisses tout à tuer une boule on vise
une trahison aller chez fogiel il
trahison bas et je balance triste que
vous m'avez proposé de faire un colis
vous étiez un poison à la cigarette
j'aime trop c'est bien bien là bravo
bravo la nicotine bravo moi j'y serai un
poisson rouge
[Rires]
si vous étiez une femme pas beaucoup oh
lola
non mais oh ça va on a le droit d'être
très grossier vendée moi je demande tout
le temps
oh la la moi j'y serai une panne
d'électricité pendant la finale de la
coupe du monde voilà tu la rendit alors
moi aussi parce que presque j'ai rajouté
la leo mccarey tu l'a plus fait un
moment à l'interné depuis 3 si vous
étiez une infirmité et les haricots des
voix septième à face à quelqu'un qui
fera un crime parfait
d'ailleurs je sais ce que c'est que le
crime parfait j'ai réfléchi c'est un
crime gratuit
parce que si c'est un acte gratuit c'est
impossible on se retrouve alors ce sera
marine a donné des bons conseils fumée
un crime gratuit parfait si vous étiez
une mort pas définitive si vous étiez à
microbes
un microbe de ahmed 80
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
double vainqueur au mercy serge même
s'il trouve que je suis mal habillé
merci quoi il a dit c'est emma beal
d'habitude et puis j'avais le public ne
sait pas quel serge khalfon s'habille
exclusivement en prada donc forcément ce
que tu vois un tee shirt il adore le
mieux habillé de paris sans réalisateur
mannequin on l'appelle le réalisateur
nick a absolument tout est entre nous tu
m'as serge tout le monde le sait a
tamponné par d'échangés
[Rires]
djamel anti porte chinois un jour casse
toi alors qu'abel tout est prêt pour
lentilles portrait chinois
[Applaudissements]
café tabac par djamel savoir culinaire
ya pas de couilles reviendra plus les
ardeurs je suis désolé je voulais pas le
faire au départ je le fais dissidente et
portrait chinois
d'accord mais montre joey starr mais là
quand même pour le côtoyer le put alors
ce qu'ils faisaient
merci ils disent et des blagues racistes
ça fait trois jours qu'il cherche
julien internes a dit [ __ ] c'est
dégueulasse
j'avais lutté près savoir heureusement
je t'ai dit si mes tantes chabot david
jamais la vo est revenu avec une armée
de ben boulaïd nemo curieux
depuis que lorsqu'il fait ses débuts des
petites semaines le début du match est
un peu la gueule ce programme six buts
muriel que je voulais pas misé j'en ai
pris un peu mais c'est la compassion
même opposition loyale et on peut tout
faire maintenant tu bouffes du nord en
bracelet maintenant tu sais que ta
chaussure droite c'est fait exprès
automobile et les tickets dit que ça
s'appelle le style alors ça s'appelle du
vol
jamais tu sais que les parents de muriel
il vend des chaussures doit aller au
tour en bond des prêts ouais si tu étais
un robot attends je vais juste vérifier
un truc
on y arrivera il est aumônier matois et
le double à quentin rappeuse dinars ces
mecs de banlieue c'était bien bon
marcheur
c
vers la scène jazz et lesbiennes étaient
trop petits
c'est très bien vasic c'est un gros mot
sa mère lipopette c'était une guerre une
guerre si j'étais une guerre voilà que
je serai là avec la guerre contre les
pointes sèches et les cheveux cataractes
c'était un accident
la coupe du monde c'était un dictateur
j'étais un dictateur charlie chaplin gt1
oui j'étais à gori le bruit qui court
que je suis pas avec juliette binoche a
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas moi c'est après l'émission
s'il était un assassin zinédine zidane
sans exception c'était une trahison
mon bras droit ces [ __ ] une équipe
pas confiance c'était un meuble un
canapé convertible pour le convertir à
l'islam qu'ils étaient un supplice voté
chirac en 2002 ça c'est un supplice
c'était un légume
j'ai pas cédé d'un terroriste carlos
papayou papayou l'aîné ça m'a tout pour
les moquettes
ou une soeur michelle pour le est rien
il était un supplice je recommence
sortant
si j'étais un supplice groupe
un 4e revers de la saison
huawei c'est incroyable que j'ai pas
envie de te taper devant tout le monde
tu fais des ckoi temps tu rigoles comme
un conte de ses blagues c'est pour ça
qu'il va aussi après des regards il ne
vous suit surenchérit arrêts en plus il
dit white spirit
je garde le regard qui s'approchent pas
du feu non mais s'en sort bien qu'est ce
que c'est ça je peux pas rester comme ça
c'est pas possible
il cahill écailles trop dans son fonds
plateau plus ça y est j'ai attrapé la
crève
renata un petit manteau pour jamel pas
une petite culotte sitechar vas-y vas-y
pardon si tu étais à l'animal mon frère
mon goût des impôts le sait très bien
les blancs d'ardeur le monde apple
je n'arrive pas tu sais pourquoi parce
que gillett avait pas beaucoup dormi si
c'était un labo mon père et si c'était
une ordure
le père noël ouais tu m'as il m'a oublié
- dernière rien ramené g que le
commander un astre accepter ces quatre
centrales epr est marina à quoi à faire
un petit portrait mais pas chinois à
l'anti portrait chinetoques marina
marina si vous étiez un élément de salle
de bain je serai un petit tapis en
plastique vous savez les trucs tous
pourris là pour fabulizés d'accord voilà
moi j'ai un peu sale de coeur celui-ci
un appareil électroménager
je serai une touillette electrica
vinaigrette parce que c'est un appareil
pour les flemmards nous j'aime bien
l'idée ce que c'est facile de tourner la
vinaigrette un lacet électrique d'accord
sujet tient un verre du deuxième groupe
pour rire pour rire voilà très bien oui
et non en bourse et troisième groupes
non mais alors expliquez moi je un
comment vous vous souvenez tous de quel
intérêt si vous étiez un meuble de
jardin
non je suis contre les meubles de jardin
j'y tiens scobee 17h36 15h et d'îles la
santé de votre entreprise multi le
niveau in vécurent en de tf1 navarro
ça ne vous gêne et je peux vous dire que
les méchants et très en prison si vous
étiez un des sept nains navarro si vous
étiez une prévision météorologique jeu
sera une grosse mine énorme dépression
sur marseille au dessus de la part de
pêche d'accord je suis venu ici un
cadeau de mariage un service à fondue
une friteuse que vous voulez
si vous étiez un outil n'importe j'adore
les outils et là je suis très
sérieusement je pète une coche je réagis
this way the nino's rodez
[Musique]
la fille
pourquoi il a bougé ou pas bien alors
lentilles pas vous connaissez le
portrait chinois le portrait chinois ces
sites étaient une fleur je serai à muse
autisme et en lentilles portrait chinois
c'est juste la mer c'est si vous étiez
une rupture par exemple une rupture de
rythme malgré le rythme mois une injure
or la vache
ah oui c'est ça non mais tu m'énerves
ces cantons une injure si on relance à
quelqu'un ou c'est très méchant qu'elle
a pu réagir
non je me pose c'est ça tu m'énerves sa
cuisse c'est tout mais c'est fou la
violence des politiques oui mais bon
mais je peux quand on va se faire
censurer tu es malade brom et ta gueule
euh pardon si vous étiez mal à nice
ville les gens aillent de grosses merdes
veut dire [ __ ] voir annoncer le
pouvoir mais je plaisante
non non j'arrive il ya des choses que je
peux dire on t'envoie dans le métier 1
si vous étiez une maladie alors une
maladie qui serait pas grave mais qui
pourrait par exemple donner de la fièvre
parce que je sais pas moi j'ai des
souvenirs d'enfant j'avais de la fièvre
c'était dans mon lit puis je sais pas
c'était un état que qui était assez
agréable jambon coquillonne quand on
était malade
non mais ça non mais juste que ça je
tournais un peu j'avais comme un comme
un vertige a donné comme un vertige
comme un truc un peu connue là et
c'était pas désagréable à la vie qui
donne de la fia n'était pas grave ouais
si vous étiez une guerre en bain une
guerre de mots alors passez moi j'aimais
bien ça alors il léguait faut regarder
ouais mais enfin quand on imite les
bruits tous âges avaient bien fait rue
voilà cinquante neuf derrière les à un
vice un vice la cour mantis si vous
étiez une arme l'humour un supplice les
jours des gens au casse et chatouille
déjà tous les châteaux si vous étiez un
poison le sucre non ouais un dictateur
un dictateur aura je vais pas être
original sûrement d'autres l'ont dit
mais enfin j'en vois qu'un c c'est
charlie chaplin way dont personne n'a
qu'un seul une infirmité timidité ouais
ça va la nourrir la sava suis bien un
assassin j'ai été un assassin
ah oui dans les pêcheurs fois non dans
des rêves mais parfois c'est très
curieuse j'aurais dû en parler un jour à
un psy jean charles ix e minute
j'ai souvent été un assassin qui
n'étaient pas pris je savais qu'il
savait que quelqu'un avait tué mais il
savait pas encore que c'était moi je
courais enfin ça doit être un truc de
culpabilité levé sentir là une torture
chatouille une humiliation gratos
tant qu'on les parties dans le très hard
si vous étiez une mort de rire si tu
étais un vice
la pire oui oui c'était le pire visent
tous avec toi la rue lâche c'est les
gens quand on l'a quand on leur fait le
portrait chinois on leur dit c'était une
fleur loreidy serait corps qui n'est là
non si tu étais un hui autre et là tu
serais là c'était une guerre tu sais
laquelle
au mas la dernière parce qu'elle était
la plus terrible où alors
et en irak c'était vraiment eric mais la
dernière guerre a été tant à la dernière
elle était femme a bien réussi oui
c'était collaborateurs tu serais si
c'était les incriminant message c'était
un grand collaborateur tu serais plus
maurice taxe parce que pas mal c'était
un supplice
oa supplice comment appelle-t-on ces
supplices ou où on écarte s'apaisent ne
laissait pas l'écarter parce que les
cartes et autres shows et gagner un jeu
de cartes le quartier lmnp les cartels
sont tus et les cartels sont peut-être
ceux ci une psychanalyse c'est une
action
mais si tu étais un accident le pire des
chaussées dans l'avion parce que je
prends souvent l'avion et comment c'est
fait à la main c'est très à la mode en
angleterre je trouve que c'est bien mais
il faut pas prendre la journée
[Musique]